So where I had left off
is we had the circuit.
We had these little
leads here.
This was kind of
our innovation.
And this is actually called a
commutator, where this part
that's connected to our rotating
piece, that's the
commutator.
And these are the brushes.
So you could imagine, you could
design them as brushes
that always stay in touch.
Kind of like the brushes
on a, what was that?
What are those cars at
the amusement park?
Bumper cars, right?
On the bumper cars you have a
pole behind your bumper car.
I'll draw that for fun.
So let's say this is
your bumper car.
Looks like a shoe
a little bit.
This is you driving
your bumper car.
And they have a pole.
And at the top of the pole,
you'll see these brushes that
are touching the
ceiling, right?
You could view that as the
same type of brush.
And what it allows is a constant
electric current to
flow through the ceiling.
I don't know what direction
it's going in.
But it allows a current to
flow through the ceiling.
And maybe your car is grounded
so the current can flow down
to ground, so that your car
could be powered by the
ceiling and not have to carry
a battery in every car.
Which would be kind of a waste
of energy and probably some
type of a health hazard
and safety risk,
et cetera, et cetera.
So those brushes on your bumper
cars might not be all
that different from the brushes
that are touching the
commutators here.
Just a little bit
of terminology.
And it never hurts to
introduce bumper car
references.
I probably should have done
them earlier when we were
learning about momentum
and things.
But anyway.
So what was happening here?
So going back to our
first video.
We have the current going
down like this.
And then if you use your right
hand rule with the cross
product, you know that the net
force from the magnetic field
is going to be downwards on the
left hand side, upward on
the right hand side.
So you have a net torque
rotating it like that.
Rotating the right out of the
page, the left into the page
or into the video screen.
Up to the point that you've
rotated 90 degrees and now
you're looking kind of, so
this side right here.
Let me do it in a different
color so you can see it.
This side is this side,
right on top.
And this side is on the bottom,
below the page.
This side is now
above the page.
If this distance is r,
this side is now r
units above the page.
And I said ideally maybe your
commutator loses touch with
the brushes at this
point, right?
Because they're popping out a
little bit, so when you're
vertical, you actually lose
touch with the brushes.
So you have no circuit flowing,
so you save a little
battery energy.
And you just let a little bit of
the angular momentum carry
this whole rotating contraption
further a little
bit to the point that
your configuration
will look like this.
So I know I keep changing
colors, but the whole
contraption will now
look like this.
OK, that's my positive,
negative, positive, negative,
current flows like this.
Now we assume that the
commutator has
gotten back in touch.
And let me color code this.
So if this side is this
color, right?
Now this is when we're looking
at top on, where it's popping
out of the screen, where
it's above the screen.
And now we've rotated 180
degrees and this side is on
this side, right?
Let me pick a suitable color.
If this side was green.
Now this side, we flip the whole
thing over 180 degrees.
And now something interesting
happens.
Remember, before we had this
commutator and everything, if
we just flipped it over, the
current, because before when
we didn't have the commutator,
the current here was flowing
down here, up here.
And before the commutator, we
had the current flowing down
here and up here.
And so we were switching
directions.
And so you would have had this
thing that would never
completely rotate.
It would just keep flipping
over, right?
Which may be useful for, I don't
know, if you wanted to
flip things.
But it's not useful
as a motor.
So what happens here?
Now this side, all of a sudden
instead of being connected to
this lead, is now connected
to this lead.
And this green side is now
connected to this lead.
So something interesting
happens.
Now the current on the left side
is still flowing down,
right, and the current
on the right side is
still flowing up.
So we're back to this
configuration except that this
contraption has flipped over.
The brown side is now on the
left and the green side is now
on the right.
And what that allows is that
those net torques are still
going in that same rotational
direction.
Use your right hand rule.
The current is flowing
down here.
So if your magnetic field is
coming to the left, then the
net force is going to be
down there and it's
going to be up there.
And so we can continue
indefinite, and we solve our
other problem.
That we will never keep twisting
these wires here.
So now using the commutator, we
have essentially created an
electric motor.
And remember I drew that little
thing, that could be
like the axle.
Maybe that turns the wheels
or something.
So if you have a constant
magnetic field and you just by
using this commutator which,
as soon as you get to that
kind of vertical point, it cuts
the current, and then
when you go a little bit past
vertical, a little bit past 90
degrees, it switches the
direction of the current.
So on the left hand side you
always have the current coming
down, and on the right hand
side you always have the
current going up.
So that the net torque is always
going to be pushing, is
always going to be rotating this
contraption down on the
left hand side and up on
the right hand side.
Coming out of the page on the
right hand side and then down
on the left hand side.
And you could actually
turn a wheel now.
You could create an
electric car.
So that is the basics
really of how
electric motors are created.
Well, there's another way
you could have done it.
You didn't have to use
the commutator.
One methodology you could have
used is you could have had the
magnetic field going until you
get to this point, and then
you turn off the magnetic
field, right?
And maybe you wait for this
situation to go all the way
180 degrees and then you turn
the magnetic field back on
again, right?
That's one possibility.
But that's maybe not as
efficient cause half of the
cycle you're not powering it.
Or maybe you switch
the direction of
the magnetic field.
Or another option, you don't
have to use a commutator.
Maybe you use some other
contraption to switch the
direction of the
magnetic field.
But this is probably the
simplest way to do it.
And I think it gives you a
general idea of how an
electric motor can be created.
And then we could play around
with the mechanics of
innovations on it.
But all electric motors are
essentially some variation of
what you have learned
in this video.
Isn't it neat to learn
something useful?
See you in the next video.